they use haiti's independence day to
protest
once again against their government but
what started off with a carnival-like
atmosphere
soon turned violent
police used rubber bullets and tear gas
against the demonstrators calling for
president juvenelle mauis to step down
protesters blocked roads and set fire to
ties in the capital porto prince
they started protesting last year
against corruption mismanagement of aid
money
and a rise in inflation a majority of
haitians
live in poverty the president has been
criticized for his handing of the
coronavirus pandemic and denies
allegations of corruption
i am in the street to demand justice for
the underprivileged masses that is my
demand
we're from the poorest suburbs we're
saying that we can no longer live like
this
we're out on the streets to demand
justice
in response to the unrest maize called
for unity as he marked the 214th
anniversary
of the death of haiti's first
independent leader jean-jacques de
sallin
today are battles for peace we ask for
union i tell everyone in the opposition
or in the government today the future
generation expects something from us
they expect a change those changes can
come in reform
but haiti has been in political crisis
as well
and now maize has been in power since
2017
but because legislative elections were
not held in october last year there's
been
no parliament in september maize
announced the formation of a new
provisional electoral council
but haiti's opposition refused to
participate and rejected its legitimacy
so with no parliament sitting waiz has
been governing by presidential decree
since january
giving him enhanced powers
we're fighting for the respect of the
laws and the respect of the constitution
february 7 2021 is the end of the
constitutional mandates for jeopardy
we will remove him from power before
them today is a day for a national
mobilization
a government which assassinated the head
of the judiciary and a student inside a
university
is a criminal government a transition is
inevitable
we ask the international community to
help us in this battle for the last
transition
the international community has called
for an end to the political impasse and
for a parliamentary election to be held
as soon as possible
the government blames violence and the
pandemic for delays to the election that
was meant to be held last year
the un has accused it of failing to
protect people against human rights
violations
with armed gangs controlling around a
third of the country
in june the president announced a
legislative election in december
but the opposition has called for a
transitional government instead
failure to hold elections before mais's
term officially ends
could leave haiti without a leader or
parliament
al jazeera